SPEAKER: How many
steps should be
between receiving a
notification and acting on it?
When notification actions
were introduced in Jelly Bean,
this number dropped to one.
Just tap an action right there.
Direct Reply seeks to
make it just as easy
to receive text input from
the user right in line
in the notification.
This involves superpowering
one or more of the actions
you add to your notification
with a RemoteInput.
This is how the system knows
to ask for input from the user,
then forward it on to your app.
This is actually
the exact same API
used to add voice input to your
notifications on Android Wear,
but it's now available
on phones and tablets.
So we'll have a
notification with an action
with a RemoteInput.
The RemoteInput is what stores
information like the hint
text-- the text that appears
before the user types anything
in-- and the key,
a unique string
used to later retrieve
what the user typed in.
The action here is
pretty standard.
Of course, we'll want to
use addRemoteInput to add
our RemoteInput object.
There's also a
setAllowGeneratedReplies method
if you want to enable Smart
Reply on Android Wear 2.0
watches.
We are trying to make things
easy for users, right?
Totally worth enabling.
There is one other
thing we need to be
aware of-- the PendingIntent
we're passing in here.
Turns out what kind
of PendingIntent
you pass in matters a lot.
For Direct Reply, the system
is doing the UI portion for us,
so using a Service
or BroadcastReceiver
is exactly what we need.
This also allows it to work
even when the device is locked.
Awesome.
But on devices that don't
support Direct Reply,
you need to start your own
UI-- namely, an Activity.
Avoid trying to
start an Activity
from a Service or
BroadcastReceiver
PendingIntent.
The notification shade
won't automatically dismiss,
and users will need to manually
unlock a locked device,
leaving users unsure if
anything actually happened.
So we'll want to use an
Activity on Marshmallow
and lower devices and the
Service or BroadcastReceiver
for our new Direct
Reply supported devices.
Now, on to the
notification itself.
The best part, Direct
Reply doesn't care
about your notification at all.
As long as you add the
action, you're good to go.
Of course, we did build
a fancy MessagingStyle.
So if you're a
messaging app, these two
go perfectly together.
Magical.
So let's say we're ready
to receive our reply
and chosen a
BroadcastReceiver, appropriate
if we're OK with only
using the main thread.
We can then use
codes such as this
to extract the text from
the intent passed in.
You'll note we use remoteInput
getResultsFromIntent
to get a bundle, and
then use that key we
passed in to the remoteInput
here to retrieve the text.
Of course, if you
stop here, you'll
notice your remoteInput just
keeps on spinning forever.
So there's one last step--
updating your notification.
Updating the
notification is how you
tell the user the
text has been saved
or the message has been sent.
For example, if you're
using MessagingStyle,
you just append your
message to the style
and rebuild your notifications.
For other styles,
you can and should
use setRemoteInputHistory,
which will append the message
or messages to the bottom
of the notification.
Now, keep in mind, I
said update, not cancel.
You want to tell the
user it succeeded,
rather than leaving
them hanging.
So add a remoteInput to
your notifications actions
to enable Direct Reply.
Check out all the links
in the description
for more information on
how it all works as you
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]